how's that that's not fair I mean
there's there's extremists in every
religion so I'll make Oh greetings
apiece how you guys doing we're at the
mastic nut and I met my my new friend
here's Tim clean for all the NFL fans
was a alumni what does that mean for
people who know alumni means that that
one boy who played in the NFL
see me lucky enough I got to play in the
NFL for a little over a season almost
two seasons
I was actually hit by a drunk driver
[Applause]
pretty bad accidents by quite some time
in the hospital damaged my brachial
plexus in my neck hit several severe
injuries actually got a vehicle rolled
several times took my career away from
me the woman that actually hit me in the
vehicle she actually was originally
arrested and the most part she got away
with a slap on the wrist I mean that's a
very sad and tragic thing to happen you
had your whole career in front of you I
mean how does that for people that day
they don't they don't think now you now
how are you looking at life now I mean
your your housing that happen
out of man
it's 1t1 years old playing for we won't
mention the team right and and then from
there it got hit by a drunk driver and
actually right now also you got
diagnosed with the lymphoid leukemia
pretty much I'm doing the best I can I'm
not giving up I won't give up no matter
what I do
the way I look at everything I try to be
as polite as I can about the situation
so many people want to sit there and
make excuses about why they can't do
stuff I'm a living phrase of why you
can't do stuff there's anything you want
to do just put it in front of you make
sure you achieve it I mean that's why I
like about so many of these companies
like you am and stuff like that they
give these people opportunities they
find people some of these people are on
the street and they sit down and give
them a chance to give my job they want
to sit down watch everybody grow and
that's one thing during this convention
I've actually seen a lot people helping
people I mean you don't really see that
very often
most noodles out for themselves they
want to sit there and see their selves
grow one thing I've seen around here is
do one to grow as the team as the unity
and that to me is amazing how do you how
do you feel you you know there's a lot
of misconceptions about a salon in this
London you asked you give them a lot of
time that's not fair I mean there's
extremists in every religion you can't
judge what a couple people do versus a
whole religion
that's like saying when that kid went
overseas and spray paint of the cars
that all Americans are gonna go over see
the spray paint a car or anything like
that I mean you can't blame everything
on one situation I mean we had bombers
over here we've had we've had to do that
literally blown up
what pregnant the pregnancy centers
they're forcing clinics and yet that
doesn't mean that everybody does it
I mean there's always going to be
extremists at anything there's people
there's some people that want to sit
there they go protest they said then say
hey treatments up there what most people
don't realize were the United States our
toilet water is cleaner than most
countries drinking water and yet instead
of sit there being happy and wow what
can I get even better at more we find
things that sit there and try to appear
and get scared about and
can I say this is one of them the Muslim
community as a whole is prosperous I
mean like we talked about earlier I mean
the biggest idea is love now how is the
biggest idea is of love how could that
be a bad thing
I mean if somebody wants them to you
says I love you that means they care
about you in their heart their soul in
the mind right so then how can that be a
negative thing what what other advice do
you have for people who are out there
and it seems that they got an excuse for
everything you know open your heart open
your mind live for each day being told
to your dying beans all day you know I
don't know if I'm gonna make it or
anything that's even a bigger reason
every morning you wake up you should
look yourself in the mirror and at least
a hundred times if it takes it sit there
enjoy yourself why I woke up this
morning what you're gonna do to better
your day what you're gonna do to better
somebody else's day how you gonna better
their day making sure every day you've
got a plan make sure every day you have
a resource to do it and if you continue
to do that every day you're going to
notice that you lose your complaints
find a way to eliminate your complaints
before they even become an existence and
all that stuff's up here people say it's
a peace of mind no it's a peace of heart
everything you live the way you live the
way you talk so many people say well I
was just having a bad day today there's
no such thing as a bad day you allowed
yourself to let the negativity affect
you more than the positivity it's all in
your mind
thank you for spending a few minutes
with us and sharing most evidence okay
you're wonderful minute Thank You Bella
faithful I know thank you very much